[Music]
imagine if our night sky looked like
this looks cool doesn't it well what's
not cool is that you'd have to live your
life with no electricity cars rockets
jewelry or your cell phone this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
lived in a globular cluster take some
cosmic dust and gas add billions and
billions of planets and a whole lot of
stars to the mix spice it all up with a
handful of gravity to hold things
together and you've got a galaxy shaken
not stirred some of those ingredients
would get clumped together the gases and
dust would merge into stars and stars
would get packed together into globular
clusters some of these clusters could
count up to a million stars stuffed into
an area 3.2 light-years across to put
that in perspective the closest star to
our Sun is about 4.37 light-years away
could a planet even exist where so many
stars are so close together first of all
the stars in a globular cluster aren't
exactly like our good old Sun there are
about 150 star clusters in our galaxy
the Milky Way in most of them star
formation stopped over 10 billion years
ago it's like a very ancient stellar
retirement home compared to those stars
are four-and-a-half billion year old son
is still a teenager if we had evolved on
an earth-like planet in one of those old
globular clusters we'd be a very ancient
and much more advanced civilization than
we are now the problem is we might not
have had a chance to evolve there in the
first place
not only are the stars in globular
clusters very old they don't contain as
many metals as our Sun does planets are
born from the leftovers of star
formations inside a globular cluster
there might not be enough building
materials for a rocky planet like Earth
to be formed even our Sun might have had
trouble forming in those conditions but
if it did it would most likely have a
stellar partner binary star systems
aren't unusual in the universe but they
are less likely to host habitable
planets that we could live on another
problem is that globular clusters are
very very dense chances would be high
that an alien star would collide with
our Sun one day but let's imagine that
we were very lucky that our Sun formed
inside a globular cluster and so did our
planet imagine that the conditions on
that earth were somewhat habitable for
us to evolve in and that we did but it
wouldn't be the same us we'd have to get
by without most of the metals available
to us here how would we create our first
tools build our homes or invent our tack
we might be stuck in the Stone Age
forever but at least we'd have an
incredible view of thousands of very
bright stars shining down on our planet
on the other hand if we figured out how
to make rockets out of rocks the
extremely short distances between the
stars would let us colonize other star
systems fairly easily space travel would
be our main gig we'd settle on other
planets and spread our human
civilization all over the globular
cluster that we lived in that is if
there were other planets to travel to
scientists don't know for sure how many
planets could form in these clusters and
they don't know if life is actually
possible inside the stellar swarm but
they are looking for signs of
intelligent life out there
I for one hope they find an ancient
alien civilization inhabiting one of the
oldest star systems in our galaxy but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]